la cantine de l'école du bois de la
garenne à voisins le bretonneux respecte
depuis le mois de juin un protocole
strict pour protéger les enfants de
lakovic avec un sens de circulation pour
éviter le brassage et le croisement des
groupes d'enfants
il y à un animateur par classe qui est
chargé de gérer le passage aux
sanitaires le lavage des mains nous
avons également la mise en place sur les
services les animateurs servent le pain
individuellement ils cervélo les enfants
ne circulent plus au sein du réfectoire
un plan de table a été établi par
classes et les élèves doit rester sur la
même table toute la semaine de service
sont effectués pour ne pas mélanger les
élèves nous n'avons jamais changé
le protocole sanitaire depuis le mois de
juin
alors qu'on aurait pu le relâcher en
septembre mais on est resté toujours sur
la même chose donc on était en avance
sur ce qui nous était demandé
dans cet autre et école élémentaire à
plaisir les élèves doivent porter le
masque en permanence et sont eux aussi
rangé par classe on doit absolument se
mettre avec sa classe donc si tu as à
d'autres copains dans une autre classe
là tu peux pas aller manger avec eux
donc c'est dommage mais si tu as des
combats dans ta classe valls et bien
faut pas que tu touches à tour avec
le coin à virus c'est normal c'est pour
faire valser pour le bien des autres
la cantine fonctionne en self une
réorganisation a dû être également fait
un animateur dj avec des gants et un
lavage de main préalable pour servir au
plateau le pen les couverts et ensuite
les enfants passent sur le sel dans
certaines cantines des écoles de la
ville la mairie a instauré trois
services objectif moins d'enfants dans
le réfectoire